you got two guys by the way i i feel i'm
not a guy that uh supports biden style
leadership but for a father as a father
you don't want to see your son go
through that it's painful i can see that
being very very painful for the family
okay from the biden side so whatever
hunter's done you know you're going to
have kids sometimes your kids are going
to do stuff that's going to be
embarrassing and that's not you know
your responsibility that kid is going to
be held responsible based on the laws
and the guidelines that the states offer
in the federal office he's going to be
held accountable to that if they pursue
him right
but stuff that he did
that has to do with the rest of the
people
that has to do with the voters and the
people he leads that's a different story
when everybody kept saying russia russia
russia you know what happened to a lot
of republicans behind closed doors and
impedance you know what people said
maybe this is true
and if it's true man what are you doing
selling out america to russia i'm not
okay for that you know even even
conserve behind
if this is true let me tell you i'm not
with it i'm not i know a lot of people
that said i'm not with it if this is
true and it wasn't true
but this is true
people are seeing it and no one's
talking about it this is when hypocrisy
hurts these guys right here when you
look at this article saying you failed
bill maher blasts twitter for censoring
post
after bombshell uh report on hunter
biden's laptop so i just went on twitter
right now can you go on google right now
and type in hunter brighton laptop
go on google and type in hunter biden
laptop okay
and zoom in a little bit so we can all
see it zoom in zoom and zoom in so go
and click on news go and click on news
yeah news zoom in a little bit more so
new york post center right yahoo
is just only covering what he said to
his mom which i think he called her a
spoiled uh the sea ward right i think
yeah okay next is what washington times
center right keep going lord new york
post fox news fox news right
uh gazette okay so so then go on youtube
go on youtube
and just go straight up on youtubes yeah
and type in type in um
type in uh um
go on cnn youtube channel just go on cnn
okay just go to their channel
click on cnn
right there go to videos go to videos
okay now go sort by recent so go up go
zoom in a little bit so the rest of us
can see not popular it's fine the way it
is so zoom in the rest of us can see
let's look at titles okay here's what
january 6 okay man who said he was
almost a school shooter okay what's the
next title something about tucker
pregnant woman claims
uh
what's he talking about the west side
west risks failure in ukraine keep going
up
okay steve bannon is coming up january 6
protesters gop governor comedians talk
about pranking okay nasa
uh republican voter rejects gop
protester storm uh presidential whatever
elon musk may be on the hook
soldiers this that's how far back now
two days january 6 i'm at three days now
uh this launch okay so then type in 100
okay nothing with no chan coming out
saying okay type in hunter biden laptop
okay
go 100 laptop okay so hunter biden
reveals new detail and 100 investigation
three months ago
hunter biden under investigation one
year ago trump pushing for special
counsel a year ago
stelter this was fox news's biggest
story last week a year ago
u.s investigation okay now here's what i
want you to do go up
and type in january sixth and the second
and the same party put in put january
6th
okay uh okay so how many ago two days
ago two days ago three days ago two days
ago keep going 22 hours ago three days
ago five days ago
ten day hey mr john malone if you're
watching this
you say you want to take cnn back to ted
turner days why don't you go read his
book
and see the last interview he does on
how disappointed he is with cnn this is
exactly why
this is why when you claim can you put
john malone's quote that he put up go to
the article that he put up this is the
guy that apparently is who is the new
guy from discovery that uh he's not the
ceo because they brought a different guy
that's the ceo i think he's the owner of
cnn if i'm not the article i sent you
uh uh uh yeah so go to whatever the
article is cnbc this is the one okay
make it a little bigger so we can all
see it john law says warner media
discovery getting rid of cnn would be
the coward coward's way out okay keep
going up let's read that one legendary
quote he has in here which i love
uh right there in the middle zoom in so
everybody can see it there's a place for
cnn's 43 billion dollar combination of
warner media and discovery billionaire
mogul uh john malone told cnbc to record
an interview that air thursday i would
like to see cnn evolve back to the kind
of journalism that it started with and
actually have journalists which would be
unique and refreshing
uh he told tv tv pioneer long time
chairman of liberty media which is a
major shareholder in discovery i do
believe good journalism could have a
role in the future portfolio of
discovery and time warner going to
present go a little lower to read the
next part on what he says go a little
lower a coward's what
way out would be to sell cnn or spin it
off and sell it right
and then he's obviously talking about
that we should go back to how journalism
was well john you ain't doing it just so
you know you are not doing it the
american and by the way we're not
journalists here we're podcasters
this is a youtube channel none of us
went to columbia to be journalists did
you go to columbia to be journalists no
sir tyler did you go to columbia to be
journalist yes you went to colombia to
be a journalist no i don't know well say
it because some people are watching
seriously did you go to columbia or no
no none of us went to journalism school
i'm a military guy i got it i went into
business he was a comedian he went into
insurance he got into he's a comedian
that's what he does he was on deaf
comedy jam funny guy cnn cnbc msnbc do
your job
we are not journalists do your job we
want to find out what is
going on here you're losing credibility
by not covering the story that needs to
be told rather you're only covering
january 6 because you're afraid
of the guy that could potentially go
run for office and that guy that could
potentially go run for office
what's his name um
donald j trump
who is right now the republican
candidate your fear is god forbid if
that guy gets elected if we tell the
story we're going to lose biden here's
the reality of it cnn whether you tell
the story or not
here's what you have to stop worrying
about joe biden and gang ain't getting
re-elected
so so what are you going to do hurt his
campaign he's not running again
you can actually do what you did to
promo and actually do some journalism
and tell us what happened with cuomo
good you told us we wanted to know we
appreciate you being transparent about
that part eventually took a while
because some people have to oust it with
what happened with chris como then
zucker gets fired and chris cuomo gets
fired andrew cuomo gets fired and it's
all a [ __ ] show for cnn that you guys
went through hey if you know biden's not
gonna get re-elected why don't you cover
this story you're already building up a
new sum anyways once you tell the story
once you tell the rest of us what's
really going on there's certain things
we have access to we don't have 40
people that their job is to go to
investigative reporting we don't do that
yet that's not our job that's your job
you do that professionally can you be a
professional and fulfill ted turner's
book and the vision that he had matter
of fact why don't you call cnn's book of
the month
first book you guys all read is ted
turner's book can you put up ted
turner's book on what it was they call
me ted or something like that if you
work at cnn whether you support the
organization or not why don't you go
read this book go listen to the
audiobook and see how he finishes the
book at the end
every employee at cnn needs to read this
book that came out 13 years ago everyone
i'd love to interview him every time we
ask him unfortunately he's not doing too
well we do anything to be able to
interview him right now we would do
anything to be able to talk to him
because he was a visionary that started
this he he's the guy that did what tnt
was a tnt tbs atlanta falcons atlanta
hawks atlanta all this stuff we
everybody in the nation became dominic
wilkins fans because of ted turner
everybody was following oh
[Music]
with you know justice with terry
pendleton with you know kenny lofton
with you know the pitchers millwood
glabbin
we all became braves fans because of
this guy
tell us the truth what is going on here
stop playing damn politics do your job
we're all relying on you to do your job
this applies to everybody and the only
reason i'm specifically singling out cnn
is because john malone had the audacity
to come out and say something like he's
just said right now saying hey we got to
go back to journalism great right we're
going to hold you to it we'd like to see
what's going on so how many of these
guys have reached out how many times has
cnn reached out well how many times has
don lemon reached out how many times has
msnbc reached out how many times has cbs
reached out how many times has abc
reached out for anything how many times
have you seen an email saying we would
like to come have you on the show
well let me let me say on october 14th
when i was outed so uh the new york post
in an accident when they had a copy of
hunter's signed authorization it they
forgot to blur out the mac shop name so
people were able to
google the mac shop figure out who i was
and the attacks started instantly
and
so did the media attacks um i had five
uh reporters
uh work their way through a customer
that was trying to leave the shop
because i had the doors locked for
coveted restrictions and just keep
people out
and uh so they burst in and then i
didn't know i was being recorded and
they kind of cornered me
um
and secretly recorded me and then that
got out and then i realized oh my god
i'm not built for this at all
and that was my first experience with
the press and they tore me to pieces
i talked to bob costello that evening he
gave me some pointers
and
the next day i felt a little bit more
confident and when i came back from
lunch break so this was october 15th
i had cnn washington post and new york
times
in front of my shop
and i was like all right i'm ready for
this i'm going to just do what bob told
me to do tell just tell him what i told
the fbi because i can't get in any
trouble if my story which is the truth
is the same story that i told the fbi
you know a year almost a year at this
time prior
and uh
so i did i told them everything and they
didn't publish a word of it it's like
they were never there and then the
washington post reached out and that's i
wanted to bring this up the cnn article
from three months ago what else happened
three months ago the washington post
admitted that the laptop was real and
the new york times admitted that the
laptop was real so cnn came out with
that little tiny they snuck it in i
watched it happen it was like late at
night they just put out this little
little article
acknowledging that the laptop was real
and that was just to cover their bum
yeah that
this doesn't work this business model
doesn't work so so there's two stories
here we're going to go back to with some
of the things to get a little bit deeper
but this business model doesn't work
people are not dumb you're not going to
win like this cnn just so you know
people know you're playing games and
they don't like it tell the story tell
us what happened tell us really what's
going on over here and let us make a
decision if it's real or not and it will
go from there but the business model
they're taking is not going to be an
effective business model long term if
you sell insurance you sell insurance
you can't say well we're only going to
sell insurance to such and such people
if you if you if you do real estate you
have to do real estate if you don't real
estate the market's not going to favor
you if you do media journalism you call
yourself a journalist well then go do
some investigative journalism and do
some digging
we're podcasters
we're just regular guys that want to see
what's going on in the world because
we're concerned about the future so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]